welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka your friendly
neighborhood spoiler man and it looks
like we have a whole host of new leaks
in regards to what's coming down the
line in the MCU tivo of the lord of the
long box youtube channel which was
recently disabled by youtube said that
there were several sources in the
industry that since told them of the
upcoming lineup of events and throughout
this video i'll be breaking down
everything that the content creator said
would be coming up in the upcoming
Marvel slate
whilst all of these leaks should be
taken with a pinch of salt there are
heavy spoilers here so if you don't want
anything potentially ruined about the
upcoming movies then I highly suggest
that you turn off now without the way I
just want to give a huge thank you for
clicking this video now let's get into
my breakdown of all the phase 5 & 6
rumors okay so first up Tebow said that
the next big Avengers endgame level
event will be Secret Wars which will be
built up to in phases 4 5 & 6 from this
earth will become battle world and will
sort of be mapped out similar to things
like Game of Thrones and Lord of the
Rings with there being several different
territories Doctor Doom will be taking
over Europe Mandarin will be controlling
Asia the Red Skull will be brought back
to control the US and US agent will work
for him before turning against the
villain the Netflix characters are also
rumored to be coming back on Hulu and
these will actually interact with the
bigger narrative unlike how things have
been in the past now whilst all of this
is going on the cosmic side of the MCU
will see the introduction of Galactus
who will make his way through what's
called the annihilation wave between
phases 4 5 & 6
TiVo said that the Galactus vs. tyrant
rumors are untrue and that Nova will be
the first Herald of Galactus who will
appear in the first Fantastic Four movie
before Silver Surfer follows in the
sequel and this is how the big film will
be introduced to the earth heroes this
is really crazy to me and I know there's
been no but Easter eggs planted
throughout the MCU so it will be great
if the character finally finally finally
gets some screen time apparently the
Fantastic Four and x-men logos have been
finished and will make their debut at
d23 this weekend
Omega Red is also planned to be an x-men
villain very soon and this could be the
first character that the group go up
against whilst that's the bigger arc of
the MCU going forward Tibo in addition
to this said the following about the
confirmed films that we have already he
said that thing Pham boom will be coming
to shang-chi and that his source has
seen concept art on the character he
also cleared up the rumor over whether
the homie Gus fring which is how our
forever Noah will be debuting in the MCU
he said that he won't be playing Norman
Osborn as Kevin Feige doesn't own the
character and tivo didn't provide who he
could be playing instead this is kind of
disappointing of its true as again it's
a perfect example of why the Sony
contract is just so restrictive I would
personally love to see Norman Osborn as
the big bad going forward but you know
Sony they're very protective of their
properties and it took absolutely ages
for Marvel to even get ahold of
spider-man so yeah I can understand why
they're holding him back going forward
with spider-man 3 Peter will hire a
lawyer tell clear his name that will be
none other than Jennifer Walters aka
she-hulk this definitely seems like a
great introduction for the character
especially with the Hulk's role becoming
less and less going forward
venom 3 will become a big part of the
MCU and we'll use the storyline maximum
carnage as its basis on the other
properties Doctor Strange 2 will open up
the multiverse and supernatural side to
the MCU Namor will become the villain of
black panther 2 and the rock is
apparently in deep talks for the role
after being upset over the budget that
DC have provided for Black Adam Keanu
Reeves wants to be Adam warlock but his
team wants him to be Moon Knight and
there is concept art for Hercules and
machine man who will apparently be
appearing in Thor love and thunder in
terms of Marvel shows apparently moon
girl is coming to the Disney Plus
streaming service though this is the
only announcement that they had finally
TiVo has not heard too much about
Deadpool but he did shed some light on
the situation which is rather
interesting and paints sort of a clearer
picture of how things will be going
forward he said that going forward the
character will be r-rated and under the
Fox banner this is just purely because a
lot of people don't really know how to
market the character or how he would be
handled
the universe so they're just trying to
keep him as separate as possible
and that's everything we know so far
there are definitely some massive
massive things in this and I kind of
feel from this line up that the MCU is
sort of just getting all of the cards in
place with phase four before they can
really bring out the big guns for the
next slate Galactus being a big villain
is something that I'm still a bit unsure
about as to me the characters more of a
force of nature than someone with a
grand plan which i think is the main
reason that Thanos was so relatable here
is someone who just drips through the
cosmos consuming things so I'm not sure
how well he will translate as even with
the scale of the character is difficult
to have a conversation with on a
one-to-one level now they may go with
something like ego the Living Planet
from guardians of the galaxy to but it
will be interesting to see exactly how
he's brought to the screen whilst this
is the rumored lineup I don't think the
marble will pull out any of these plot
points during the d23 panel and I think
this info will be saved for down the
line in order to keep the hype train
going
we do have rumors that black panther 2
will be released on February 18 20 22
and then it will be followed by
guardians of the galaxy vol 3 which will
drop on May the 6th of the same year
Marvel are clearly lining up for some
big things and if they pull this one off
we could be in for another amazing 10
years of movies obviously I'd love to
hear your thoughts on this news and if
you hype for it or still a bit skeptical
comment below and let me know and if you
enjoyed this video then please like it
make sure you check out my breakdown of
who the father of Peggy Carr as kids is
Maude will finally confirm this so it's
definitely worth checking out if you
have any questions about the Avengers
and gang timeline if you want to come
talk to me about movies TV shows games
and comic books then you can follow me
on twitter at definition whitey it's the
best way to get in touch with me and
it's the perfect place to suggest new
videos and content so hopefully I see
you over there after this also just want
to let you know that we're currently
giving away a free copy of John wick 3
on blu-ray and all you have to do to be
in with the chance of winning is to like
this video make sure that you subscribe
to the channel and leave your thoughts
on the phase 5 & 6 line up in the
comment section below the winner will be
chosen at random on September the 10th
and the
be shipped out from then to ever gets
the prize it's the best of luck to
everyone who takes part this is a
channel for people who are super into
superheroes so if that's the kind of
thing you like hit subscribe thanks
again for taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]